hello everyone a very warm greeting to
one and all my name is shrii and I would
like to welcome you all for today's
webinar on omx logic multiomic research
program so before we begin with today's
webinar for those of you who are joining
with us for the first time let me take a
brief moment to introduce you to the
team behind the program we are a
us-based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
Commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools tools and our
mission is to make B informatics more
accessible from specialized training
courses to research services that
provide expert guidance and support we
are committed to providing comprehensive
solutions for all your om data needs and
so far we have had the opportunity to
work with coordinators from different
parts of the world to offer bi
informatics training programs across
24,000 participants in 187 countries AC
across different specialization tracks
such as oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine neuroscience and so
on and in this webinar we will introduce
you to omix logic multi omix research
program and learn how this program can
help Propel your research journey in
om's data
analysis now this program offers an
unpar opportunity to work independently
on a research project using
bioinformatics and data science and with
alongside Mentor support we can delve
into omix research gaining hands-on
experience to make meaningful
contributions to the field of biomedical
research now if you're a student who
lacks a prior background in
bioinformatics we also provide training
plus research option where students will
First Complete specialized training
modules on our centralized learning
platform called omix logic learn portal
and this Learning Journey involves
Mentor guided lectures online courses
and example projects on topics ranging
from introductory bioinformatics
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics AP
genomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using R and Python and
throughout the duration of the training
period we closely Monitor and track the
learning progress of students and upon
completion of the training phase
participants will be able to seamlessly
transition into the research phase of
the program
now during the research phase
participants will engage in a thorough
literature review on their chosen
research topic and work closely with the
mentor to identify and access relevant
data set for their research
project now for analyzing this chosen
project data set by the student we give
multiple options for instance you can
analyze the data without any coding at
all and for those interested in opting
the non-code pathway they will be given
directions to access the T binfo
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data and this platform
includes demo pipelines and Analysis
Cloud infrastructure to run various BMA
pipelines and for those interested in
learning to analyze data through coding
we provide Google collab notebooks which
will help you develop coding skills
while learning popular packages in R
programming and python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
biological data and at the end of the
project students will submit their work
to data repositor such as GitHub and
publish their completed project on the
omix logic learn
book now here's a quick glimpse into the
various ways that students have
leveraged these resources to work on
different research specialization track
so for instance our python training
program was part of the systems medicine
graduate program conducted at the
Georgetown University and the training
ended with students submitting their
research project on the OM logic learn
portal and as you can see students have
developed machine learning models using
python to address research questions in
various disciplines including infectious
diseases metabolic disorders
Neuroscience oncology and so on and
further students also have the
opportunity to participate in poster
presentation competitions and in
exciting cash prices and twice a year we
conduct omix research Symposium wherein
we invite experts from all around the
world and provide their feedback for the
students research work now there are
also examples of student research
Publications and here is one example of
rwi who was an undergraduate student who
conducted transcriptomic analysis on
data set from multiple sclerosis
patients and published her research in
an Open Access journal on immunogenetic
gentics saner is another student who
went on to complete an oncology based uh
research project on leukemia and
published her research in Colombia
undergraduate research journal and the
student projects are not just limited to
graduates and doctorates for instance
Andre was a high school student when he
participated in the research program and
he completed a neuroscience project that
he presented at the regen Ron
international science and engineering
fair for which he won the pamin prize
and these projects can also be showcased
for higher studies and University
applications like some of our research
students have done as deara dkin who got
accepted to the Aris Mundus imbc program
in Marine Biology Dru mea who got
accepted to the Precision medicine
graduate program at University of
Manchester and Anusha who had accepted
to the PHD program and faculties and
researchers have also collaborated
through our programs to publish their
research work and here's one of the
latest collaboration that we conducted
with a team of researchers at nuchi
Memorial Institute for medical research
at the University of Ghana and it is
also possible to pursue an
entrepreneurship and business Innovation
track like a team of industrial
researchers from a biotechnology company
in Nigeria de so they developed a
microbiome test kit to improve the
fertility of women in Nigeria and such
tracks are pursued not only by
researchers but by undergraduate and
postgraduate students as well for
instance this was a group of students
who worked on developing an early
detection kit for Alzheimer's disease
using metagenomic data sets and now we
consistently share these updates on
ongoing research project outcomes
student Publications exciting job
opportunities and latest article on on
our social media platform we'll share
the link to our LinkedIn group where you
can explore all of these updates so now
I'll take you to our centralized
learning platform which is the omx logic
learn portal that I covered in my
previous slide where you can explore the
various courses and example projects
that be
C so here is the link to the portal I'm
sharing it in the chat box
so for those of you who have not created
an account yet this uh just follow along
the steps uh that I'm sharing right
now so here in the link if you already
have an existing account on the portal
you can simply uh enter your existing
email ID and password and just directly
login or if you're someone who is
creating an account for the first time
let me show you if you're creating an
account for the first time click on the
login option that you see here and here
click on the create an account option
and then here you'll be asked to enter a
few details such as your name email ID
password your
University um and so on you can enter
those details and create an account or
you can also log in using any of your
existing social media handles this could
be your Google account Facebook account
Apple account GitHub account or even
Twitter
so since I already have an existing
account on the portal I'm going to click
on login now and login using my existing
email ID and
password so I'll pause for a couple of
seconds for the participants to log in
or create an account if you have not
created yet and once you have created an
account please let me know in the chat
box with the yes and for those of you
who already have created an account
please put it done in the chat box
all right Jam has already created an
account perfect user has also created
Sachi has also
created and along the way if you're
facing any technical issues in uh
creating an account or you're not able
to recover your old account you can
reach out to us as well and we'll be
able to um assist you in creating the
accounts all right we have multiple
participants who have already created an
account thank you so
much all right so I'll quickly walk you
through on the first steps as well as
how you can explore this uh portal so on
the blue bar on the top you will see
welcome back with your email ID so when
you click on that it will direct you to
setting up your profile
so that is the very first thing that you
need to do when you create an account to
be able to do that just click on the
profile button that you see here and
make sure that your name is in proper
capitalization since when you complete
the courses and the programs the name
will be uh automatically generated on
the certificate that you have provided
in this section and add a brief bio
about yourself so you could mention
about your educational background and
your research interest and also Link in
your your social media handles so in my
case I've linked my LinkedIn account and
my orc ID and also add a profile image
so once everything is completed it
should be showing profile completion
100% all right and this is the activity
bar where we track the learning progress
of the participants and make sure that
they are uh Qui to move into the
research phase of the program once they
enroll and under the courses T you'll be
able to monitor the course progress that
the students are making
as well and once the project has been
published that will dis that will appear
under the projects tab here and the
programs tab will display any of the
training programs or the research
fellowship program that you are
presently enrolled in and once you
complete all the required quizzes
assignments and submission of the
project the certificates will appear
under the certificate staff so that was
all that I wanted to cover in uh this
discussion so now to learn more about
the research fellowship program
structure what are the various research
specialization tracks I would like to
pass on the stage to my colleague
missar to take over the session over to
you thank you so much
Shari can you confirm if my screen is
visible it is loading yes now we can see
all right perfect uh a very warm good
evening to everyone present here good
morning good afternoon in which part of
the world you are hope you all are doing
great and uh I'll be today taking you
through the research fellowship program
structure and we'll also discuss about
uh the different possible omix analysis
that you can work on different research
specialization tracks also the flow of
omix analysis that you would be working
on and uh different tools and techniques
that you can use and we'll also showcase
you some of the data sets it's not
possible to go through in-depth overview
of each and every omix analysis in the
session though but I'll try my level
best to just give you a taste of what
all different omx fields and tracks you
can work on and uh if you join the
program what would the flow be like so
let's first of all try to understand
what is the program all about so as
students embark on their professional
Journey with freshly completed degrees
they often wonder how the professional
life will be different from studies and
and many prepare for this moment in
advance by exploring the possibilities
to work in an area of Interest through
internships or research fellowships
during their studies and this process
starts with a program that we have
designed to introduce students or even
researchers from all the backgrounds to
the intersection of biology and data
science and we call it omix logic not
just students even past out students or
PhD fellows or researchers who are from
different fields but they want to learn
about a specific type of omix analysis
are most welcome to join the research
Fellowship training program work on a
research project with one particular
data set get a taste of the analysis get
good hands on with the analysis and be
all set to uh embark on a New
Journey now what is the research program
structure so we follow the research
program in three different steps the
first step is to get you trained so you
go through an introduction to different
omx feed you go through an introduction
to different resarch specialization
tracks if you're not aware of and then
you pick up one we train you in that
specific type of omix analysis and then
we get started with your research so
once you are trained in a specific field
of omix analysis after that you review
literature come up with the research
question that you would like to work
upon or if you uh don't have a research
question we have a set of research
questions and data sets that we have
already prepared for you that will take
you through towards the end of this
session you can be a part of that
project work on a project and have your
report ready now this report that you
work on could be for any number of
reasons one it could be a desertation
that you want to submit in your college
or university or for experience or for
your PhD application or a job
application or if you want to switch
your field from uh one to another maybe
get into bioinformatics with a specific
type of omix experience that you want to
get through this program all right so
once you have your research question
defined you work on a research project
closely with the mentor where you
discuss your uh project flow discuss
your um gaps where you are stuck while
carrying out your research discuss the
methodology with your Mentor the mentor
would guide you on each and every step
of how do you of how you have to proceed
with your research work discuss what
should be your next steps and that is
the way you proceed forward and towards
the end of the research work you will
have a report or a publication
whatsoever is your requirement so that
are the three simple steps we follow in
the research fellowship
program all right now the question is uh
what all would you be going through so
when I said training or getting started
I meant going I me taking you through an
introduction to bioinformatics training
program and the another course or
program that we have put together this
pites and molecules to give you a taste
of different resource specialization
tracks you pick a specific field it
could be genomics it could be
transcriptomics or single cell or metag
genomics maybe or multiomics if you want
to cover each and every aspect of omix
based on your research question and then
you gain the expertise on specific tools
and softwares that could be used for
carrying out the analysis on your
specific uh omx data type that you're in
Ed to work upon when I say tools or
softwares it could be Computing
languages programming languages r or
python that you should be uh efficient
with at least one language uh if you
want to succeed in the field of
bioinformatics using or working with big
data and then specific tools and
softwares associated with each and every
different type of omx data that you
would be working on now what are the
different resarch specialization track
that you can pick so once you have
gained an expertise with a specific type
of omx data the next step is to pick up
a field of research that you would like
to work on either it could be oncology
or Precision medicine or infectious
diseases or metabolic disorders or
Neuroscience or system biology or
agriculture space omics or maybe chem
informatics if you're confused with
specific field to focus on then you can
definitely explore the omx logic learn
portal where you have these different
projects in in different fields you can
explore them get an idea we are here to
assist you with each and every different
type of field and then we can pick up a
question for you all right so that was
all about what the structure would be
like what all different resarch
specialization tracks you can pick from
now what's included in the program uh a
question that a lot of you ask so you
you start with the training process in
the training process you will be given
uh recorded lectures you will be given
asynchronous uh course workk that you
can go through at your own pace we
understand that you might be working
professionals or or students and might
not have specific uh time that you can
dedicate to uh the live lectures that's
why we have given you recorded lectures
and also asynchronous coursework go
through them and then get back to us
with any of the doubts that you might
have you'll be supported with the te bio
info platform uh to learn how different
pipelines could be used for carrying out
omix analysis I'll also tell you what
are the capabilities of the platform and
how you can leverage it the most and uh
then you'll be given RN python code
collabs as well to get a good Hands-On
practice with r or python collabs or
code blocks for different types of
analysis guidance by uh guidance by
mentors experts on specific research
projects that you'll be working with and
towards the end when you have to work on
a research publication let's say or
simply have your desertation put
together we'll be assisting you in uh
writing your manuscript or your
desertation project and you could get a
uh get you could get a recommendation as
well for your applications that you
would like to push for your Masters or
maybe PhD and you also can uh can take
assistance for any proposal writing for
for the grants or maybe research
projects that you would like to
pursue now there are different uh
research applications of omic studies
that we discussed and different omic
studies as well that I just mentioned
that you can either pick one of these
omic studies that you would like to work
upon so I'll take each one of these omx
types one by one and let's just try to
understand what type of analysis you
could do under each one of these omix
fields so the first one is genomic data
analysis uh for genomic data analysis
you could have these faster or fastq
files from different repositories you
take these different files and perform
two very specific type of analysis
either phenetic analysis or variant
calling there are more such research
questions that you can Gater to with the
genomic data that you get from public
repositories this is just an idea that
you can start with now there are two
things that I would like to discuss one
is the code platform or the code pathway
and another is the non-code pathway so
for the non-coders code biologists we
have these pipelines put together that
you can run through and get your results
and focus more on biological
interpretation and Reporting your
findings rather than the core analysis
or the coding that you might not be well
equipped with and for uh core coders or
bioinformaticians who want to follow the
code path we'll take you through the
training of r or python if you're not
well equipped with and then we follow
the code path to answer your research
questions okay next is transcriptomic
data analysis I'll be explaining the
non-code path and code path for each one
of these omix fields for transcript toic
analysis you'll be taught in in your
training how to carry out seek analysis
right from having the data in hand to
how to prepare the data how to explore
the data then you go to the downstream
analysis and then uh towards functional
characterization or further biological
interpretation if you follow the
non-code path you have the tbio info
platform where you would like to know
what type of pipelines you could run
when you talk about the pipelines the
first question is what tools am I going
to use and for those those tools what
those tools do why would I be using a
specific type of tool and not the other
and also what parameters do I use on
what basis do I set those parameters so
all these questions would be answered
during the training process where you
will be taught about each and every tool
how these uh tools vary why do we have
first of all different tools for one
single type of analysis or maybe step in
our analysis and then very usual Excel
how to use Excel for statistical
analysis one very common thing that we
have seen in biologists they are not
able to use Excel for General
statistical analysis and also how do you
use or go through the code pathway how
do you use r or python for carrying out
the analysis for exploring data for
carrying out the analysis uh and if it
is transcriptomic analysis then how do
you carry out biological interpret ation
Downstream analysis and functional
characterization using r or
python now the question is where do you
find such data because if your students
or uh researchers were interested to
learn about a specific type of omx field
but don't have such type of data where
do you get it from so there are
definitely lot of repositories that you
can explore the question here is how do
you extract the data from these
repositories and most importantly how do
you find the right data set that you can
use for your research project now there
are many data sets for which already a
good research has been worked upon so
why do you even pick that data set what
type of research question can you answer
with that data set and how to you
extract this data make sure that the
data is accurate for your analysis
prepare that data and then there are
several other steps that you need to
follow explore the data try to
understand what's examples do you have
or what is the variance between them
I'll just go through it step by step so
these databases could be Geo gene
expression Omnibus which stores the gene
expression and molecular abundance data
or tcga which stores the genomic and
clinical data you have fire brows that
will provide access to tcga data
analysis tools Sr is there that is
sequence read archive that uh will give
you the access to Raw sequencing data
from various High throughput sequencing
platforms expression Atlas host gene
expression data from different species
and cell types and en stores nucleotide
sequence data including raw sequencing
reads and assembled genomes as well and
then you have gpn that is gene
expression profiling interactive
analysis uh which stores or offers gene
expression analysis based on tcga and
gex and then you have the human protein
Atlas that contains the protein
expression profiles in human tissues and
cells and these are just some of the
databases that we'll take you through
there are more such databases that we'll
cover in the training program for
pathway analysis or geneontology or
functional analysis maybe now as I said
that you have these fast Q files or
faster files once you have these faster
files or fast VI files and you want to
generate a gene expression table uh if
you don't have the uh facility of uh
good high Computing system that you
could use or if you don't have a
Proficiency in Linux maybe or a bash
where you can generate a gene expression
table then we have the pipeline on the T
bio info server that can generate the
gene expression table for you from the
fast file or the fast Q file now what do
I mean by generating a gene expression
table from the raw read so this specific
set is this specific step is called
pre-processing of reads into a gene
expression table and it is crucial for
removing the noise or the bies and the
artifacts which ensures accurate
Downstream analysis now there are
several challenges that include data
heterogenity and quality as well which
the tbio info server pipeline addresses
through standardized pre-processing
protocols and quality control measures
as well which enables reliable and
reproducible Analysis now there are two
set of uh students or researchers that
we have observed one who want to follow
the non-code pathway and the other ones
that want to follow the code pathway the
non-code pathway this is the APT
pipeline that they could use and for the
um and for the coders we soon have a
program launched in bash where they
could learn how they can use how they
can generate a gene expression table now
coming on to the next step that is data
preparation once you have the gene
expression table in your hand what next
the next step is data preparation data
preparation of this gene expression
table involves processing raw sequencing
dat data into a table format that will
list the genes and the corresponding
expression level and this process will
include the steps such as alignment to
reference genome quantification
expression level uh and then you have to
normalize your data to correct for biis
filter it to remove low quality or
irrelevant data and then you have the
final gene expression table that serves
as the basis for Downstream analysis
before even getting into the downstream
analysis it's important for you you to
explore your data and understand what
types of samples do you have what are
their characteristics what is the
variance between the samples if there is
any and is it good enough to proceed
ahead for Downstream analysis or not so
explanatory analysis basically it's an
approach to analyze the data sets to
summarize their main characteristics
often employing different visual methods
it involves techniques such as plotting
histograms or Scatter Plots box plots to
understand the distribution the
correlation and patterns within the data
expiratory analysis basically aims to
uncover these insights identify the
patterns and also detect the outliers
that provides a foundation for further
analysis or hypothesis
generation after exploratory analysis
you can perform dimensionality reduction
to uh look for the specific outlines
understand the sample variance and from
simple bar plots to complex timer
deduction techniques like PCR clustering
for data mining you can also use several
uh clustering algorithms to Cluster the
samples together and try to understand
uh if there is any batch effect maybe in
your study and if it is well enough
accurate enough to proceed ahead for
Downstream analysis or if you have to
remove some of the outlines that you
might have in your
study so this is what the uh server
Pipeline and the results look like and
on the server you have these uh files
that you would get to download so on the
server you'll also have a dashboard and
uh it helps you interact with your
results and change the parameters real
time and see how your results uh vary or
change so that you could report the
findings after differential expression
the next step is functional
characterization where you want to
understand the gene onology understand
the Ed Pathways or the genes as well so
you perform pathway analysis and
function annotation too and also look
for the specific type of uh
differentially expressed genes in the
pathways as present so that was about
transcriptomic analysis an overview
where you could use uh the automated
pipelines or an alternate method where
you could learn how to go through R and
try to replicate the entire process
using Code blocks yourself have your
file generated and have your results
generated I'll take you through a collap
to give you a taste of how the um how
transatomic analysis in collab looks
like next feel is metagenomic analysis
for some of you this might be a new
field but a lot of research uh is being
done in this field these days so
metagenomic analysis is a method that is
used to study the genetic material that
is recovered directly from the
environmental samples and this approach
is particularly useful for understanding
the microbial communities which includes
bacteria or viruses and even fungi in
many of which um many of which that
cannot be cultured in the lab and for
metagenomic analysis there are two major
pipelines that are being used one is the
data two Pipeline and another one is the
kind to Pipeline and for these two
pipelines you get to know what are the
microb IAL abundances in your sample
what is the abundance of different
microbial communities in your sample or
between your samples and also you get to
know about the alpha diversity and the
beta diversity within the samples this
is just an overview what the field
metagenomic is all about and what type
of analysis could be done also phenetic
analysis could be done on metagenomic
studies uh that we can talk about more
in detail sometime later so that was
about metagenomic analysis one way is
you use these automated pipelines and
also we have uh proper coursework put
together using R for metagenomic
analysis so what are the specific
packages that could that are to be used
and what type of plots you can create
what type of analysis you can do using
uh these specific packages is what we'll
take you through in the training process
and then you work on your
project now another interesting field is
single cell
transcriptomic uh single cell
transcriptomic studies now here I want
to give you an example of what single
cell to make you understand what single
cell arnc study is all about so just
think of B Arn as extracting the juice
from a mix of fruits where you get a
delicious blend but lose the individual
flavors of each fruit so it's like
getting a broad view of gene expression
in a tissue where everything is combined
and now imagine single cell
transcriptomics as examining each fruit
separately savoring the unique taste and
also the character of each one so it
basically allows you to zoom in and
understand the gene expression at the
level of individual cells revealing
their distinct identities and behaviors
within a tissue that is what single cell
transcriptomic studies is all about here
you have the single cell data that is a
set of computational techniques used to
analyze and also interpret the data that
is obtained from single cell sequencing
experiments and unlike traditional
sequencing methods that provide us with
an averaged signal from many cells
single cell sequencing uh will capture
the genetic information from these
individual cells and the individual
cells as we are showing you as I'm
showing you an example here that uh it
allows you to understand a more detailed
examination of the cellular differences
and also gives you a better
understanding of the complex biological
systems in terms of what is happening
inside each and every
cell so uh this is what the Single Cell
analysis pipeline looks like it's quite
complicated single cell process is quite
complicated we have tried to simplify
this for you uh if if you are one of
those students or re or researchers who
is interested in the Single Cell studies
we'll take take it through this process
where we'll first of all try to help
we'll uh help you understand the entire
process what the workflow of single cell
studies look like and then also we'll
dive into the r and Python scripts to
develop these different plots to
understand the heterogenity of
cells single cell data analysis is a
rapidly growing fed and due to its
potential uh to look for the cellular
heterogeneities in healthy and disease
tissues uh it contributes to
advancements in Precision medicine and
our overall understanding of Bio biology
at the most fundamental unit of life
that is the
set and as students you can also conduct
research projects around different
topics on CH informatics or computer AED
drug designing as well and address
questions around the integration of uh
different biological iCal and chemical
data sets to discover new drug targets
maybe or look for drug molecules that
could be repurposed or perturbations or
also use of molecular modeling to
simulate and optimize the drug protein
interactions also perform virtual
screening for Rapid identification of
potential therapeutic compounds or maybe
perform network analysis to elucidate
the complex biochemical Pathways and the
application of machine learning to
predict the molecular Behavior maybe
based on chemical structure uh so this
is also one of those areas that you can
work
on and these were all the different
types of omix fields that you can pick
when you want to work on your research
project now comes the tools and the
techniques that you can use so for all
of these different omix fields there are
several uh tools and techniques that you
can use to analyze your data and I want
to talk here about data science and
machine learning as data science um has
significantly enhanced biomedical data
analysis research by enabling the
extraction of meaningful insights from
the large and complex data sets it
facilitates the identification of
disease biomarkers it helps you predict
the treatment outcomes or maybe
personalization of medicine through
Advanced Techniques such as machine
learning or statistical modeling and bio
informatics so we'll take it through a
process where you'll try where you'll
learn about what are the different types
of machine learning what are the
different types of algorithms used uh
under each type of these ml methods be
it supervised unsupervised or
reinforcement learning and what are the
different types of tools that could that
you can leverage under the field or the
scope of data science to extract
meaningful insights from your omix data
now I want to address here one of the
very um main questions that is y t
bioinfo platform so I want to explain
here the difference between how using
the tbio info platform can be helpful
and how using the code pathway could be
helpful so the tbio info platform is
designed to help researchers work with
big orx data more efficiently and does
this through pre-built pipelines that
automate the complex analysis tasks such
as genomics transcriptomics and more and
these pipelines save time and effort
allowing researchers to focus on the
biological interpretation of their
results rather than getting bogged down
in technical details and the tbio info
platform is especially useful for non-
coder biologists who may not be familiar
with running complex code or setting up
high high performance Computing system
systems maybe and instead of spending
time learning the code languages or
managing computational resources
researchers can use the tbio enforce
userfriendly interface to perform
Advanced analysis that would otherwise
require High computational systems so
this makes T bio info an Ideal tool for
students who are working on projects
with tight deadlines as it can help
overcome the technical barriers and also
complete their research in a shorter
time period and for the coders we have
the pathway defined take the data learn
how to use uh specific programming
languages that you are interested in it
could be r or it could be python also
based on your research question what it
demands what uh packages in R python
could be helpful for your uh specific
research question and then you have your
analysis performed so these are the two
major Pathways that we'll take you
through in your research fellowship
program
now I would like to take you through
some of the data sets that uh we have
put together uh those are literally just
few of them just to give you a taste of
what type of uh data sets can you work
with before I get into the data sets
this is what I wanted to show you so
when I say that we also follow the code
path how do we follow that we usually
work with Google collapse because is
working with Google collapse is quite
collaborative I'll say if you're working
with a specific code block and if you
have some specific question or you uh
encount any error we can simply exchange
the links and we can assist you
accordingly so this is a Google collab
for transcriptomic data analysis I took
you through a brief overview of what the
workflow for irek analysis looks like
where you look for differential Express
genes you generate a volcano plot you
look at the up or the down regulated gen
and then you carry out pathway analysis
and then you look for uh the affected
Pathways or the genes as well uh the
plots are not showing up right now
because it have to be run but you can
create different types of plots here to
understand what type of Pathways your
dgs are involved in or also learn about
the geneontology of your DS Okay so that
is how you can work with r or python now
how do you learn this this collab can be
specifically used while you're working
on a research project but how do you
start this learning process so as shrii
already introduced you to the omx logic
learn portal we have put together here
different courses on different omix
fields and different tools and
techniques that you can use um to
analyze your big data now to get started
if someone is is interested in learning
R so the first process would be to take
you through the r course work we'll not
just give you this collab to start
working on we'll definitely train you
first of all to so that you have a good
Hands-On with r you are well familiar
with what packages to use how to use
what should be the scripts um etc etc so
I'm just giving you an example of one of
the lessons here what the lessons inside
the coursework looks like so inside the
lessons you you will have the
explanation of the package let me Zoom
my screen a little
bit inside the lesson you'll have an
explanation of uh what packages are
being used what do they do then you have
the syntax given uh an explanation of
that specific syntax and then uh for
different visualizations what the code
should be and then you have these
interactive plots given here that you
would get from the code blocks now it's
also a challenge for by some some of the
biologist I say the beginers the new
bees to be able to understand or
interpret these plots how do you
interpret the results from these plots
just getting the plots is not uh like
what we want we want to understand the
insights from it as well so you have the
explanation of the plots given as well
what these uh plots are trying to say of
what type what interpretation can you
make from these plots right so that is
what is being explained you have here
different visualizations and just give
you a quick overview uh different plots
you complete the specific step histogram
density plot heat Maps towards the end
you have some practice codes as well and
once you have a good Hands-On uh with a
specific type of code block and only
then you are taken up next to work on
your research project using the same uh
code block so that was one thing another
thing is there are several open-source
tools and databases that you can use as
well inside the databases as well there
are several tools that you can use for
analysis so we'll also take you through
the process of going through these
different databases tools integrated
inside the databases and different tools
open source tools that you can use uh
that could be helpful to you for your
analysis now let me uh give you a
glimpse of some of the data sets so we
have shortlisted uh
some data sets from different omic
fields for genomics metag genomics
transcriptomic single cell and uh also
the G informatics field we have some
data sets and structures ready that you
can take up and uh start working on for
your research project as January is that
time period when uh many of you have to
work on your desertation projects uh you
can leverage these data sets or work on
with a specific analysis with us now
here you have two options either you
want to work on this specific research
project independently or if you are a
group of students uh and you want to
work on a group of your own or maybe if
you want to work on a group then we can
have your group here so a group project
or an independent project both of the
possibilities are there now let's talk
about those data sets that we have
shortlisted that uh you can work on I'll
not go in much depth of it I'll just
tell you what topic uh is for the data
set and if you have a specific interest
then you can reach out to us or uh it
might also happen that I might not
discuss a specific topic of your
interest let us know if uh you have a
topic of your interest maybe we can look
for for a data set for the same and then
help you frame your research question
and work on it accordingly so the first
data set is on cervical cancer sample
samples of patients and it has got 48
samples and the another one is this data
set is one of my favorite data sets that
uh we have been working on to explore
the different uh uh multiclass samples
it has uh different blood platelets
samples from lung
pancreas um breast and also Etc or GBM
samples are there CC samples are there
so it has got good number of samples and
we could together explore these
different samples and try to extract
insights from it the another data set
that we can work together uh is on sle
and it's an autoimmune disorder and then
you have another data set on metastatic
and localized human pancreatic
neuroendocrine tumors this is one of
those data sets that um we have the
research questions ready already for it
so the data sets that I'm showing you
right now we have the research questions
framed for these data sets obviously
different from what was addressed by the
researchers in this paper but we can
definitely leverage these data sets as
lot of uh more insights could be taken
out from the data sets that are there on
the public
repositories and then another one is on
gastric cancer diffused type gastric
cancer to be more specific and lung
cancer where you have the lung cancer
and control s samples and the sample
size is 91 now apart from Geo we have
also uh taken out some samples um
shortlisted some data sets from Ena and
Sr as well so uh on Ena there is a very
beautiful study on metagenomic data
which has thousand subjects uh it's an
Indian data set and uh it has got
different factors such as BMI lifestyle
dietary habits and genders and and this
can be a very extensive and nice study
uh taking into consideration these
different factors and um explore the
microbial
abundances um for the all of these
different uh factors that we could
analyze and we have more research
questions based on just one data set
that we can address we can discuss that
based on the on your interest so if
you're interested in any one of these
data sets you can let us know we can
discuss the research questions that you
that you can pick up and uh the last one
that I want to take you through is uh
the SR repository on SR there are
several metag genomic and genomic data
sets that you can explore as time is a
constraint here in this webinar right
now that's why I could not go through a
lot of data sets but just giving you
some examples of what type of data sets
can we work upon and uh here is another
data set it is again from Indian
population uh to study anemia and the
gut microbiome composition in R rural
udisha
population so these were some of the
data sets that I wanted to show you and
if you have a specific interest a
specific topic of your interest feel
free to reach out to us you can also
explore these repositories and look for
a data set maybe or if you have any
issues exploring the repositories you
can get back to us and uh we can have
your research question
framed that was all that I wanted to
discuss if there are any questions
please feel free to post it in the chat
box and then I'll be heading it over to
Shan
now uh thank
youal so hello
everyone uh I'm shabna from
omik so here shna your voice uh is Fe
can could you be louder
please uh am I audible now sonalika yes
better thank
you okay hello everyone I'm shabna from
omix logic so atomics logic we believe
in offering an extensive and flexible
research Journey for you so I would like
to give you a brief overview about the
research program that we offer so here
it is so the research program we have is
in three levels that is beginner
intermediate and advanced
one first of all I'll start with the
beginner one so beginner works on
predefined Research topics ging
experience in research projects designs
and omix data analysis so you will gain
hands-on experience in Project design
omix data
analysis and we will take you on a journ
of data collection mastering data
validation interpretation and project
presentation as well it is a perfect
kickart for your bioinformatics journey
so you can get started with it and uh
exess will be provided for two months
next we have is intermediate level which
focuses on exploring various research
opportunities for you using various omix
data types across specialized skills
building upon the beginners Foundation
this intermediate level introduces
research specialization tracks and
infectious disease neurosciences
metabolic disorders as s nalika told you
already so next we have is advanced
level for those who are seeking a deeper
understanding advanced level focuses on
publication ready research covering
Advanced tools data signs are machine
learning and programming in python as
well so we help you in your publication
Journey as well by reviewing your
research
manuscripts so AMX logic in short
provides a dynamic customizable Journey
For You Through the word of bi
informatics so now moving on to the
pricing of the
program we have different pricing I'll
show you
by first of all I'll be showing you in
USD
pricing so for the research duration of
two months there you can dedicate 2
three hours a day the cost for research
infrastructure will be
$350 and for the students who are
applying in groups can be enrolled for
$300 and for various scholarship
opportunities you can contact us at
communication atomics logic.com we will
definitely provide you with several
discount opportunities and resarch
scholarship opportunities available so
for 3 months duration you can enroll for
$700 and a discount scholarship for
students participating in groups will be
$550 and for six months duration it will
be
$150 and for the students participating
in groups can be enrolled for $900 now
I'll be showing you the pricing in
INR so pricing in INR will
be 24,000 for a short project and
scholarship for University or groups
will be 20,000 similarly for the 90 days
project it will be 33,000 and 208,000
INR for group projects for the advanced
level research program it will be 42,000
Kar for 128 days and it discount can be
provided like 35,000 for the group
projects and for 180 180 days if someone
wants to go for publication they can
enroll for
60,000 and the discounts provided will
be 45,000 so similarly here I will show
you on
your program page you can can change
your country from
here and you can check your pricing in
your region for example I'm taking I'm
changing it in Nigerian currency so you
can see the pricing from here
and the changed currency similarly in
that way you can check the pricing for
INR
USD so now I will tell you about uh
frequently asked questions that are
asked by students so for scholarships
and other discounts you can contact me
at communication atr.com so I'll provide
you a customizable plan that suits
better for you so what is the frequently
asked questions that are asked by
students with us firstly is who is the
program designed from so the program is
designed for students in high school
graduation postgraduation working
Professionals in the felds of bomatic
biotech Pharma nutrition health and
wellness and diagnostic Industries so
next question that I hear from students
is can I utilize this training as
requirement for a university
internship major project minor project
company internship or industrial
training so yes definitely you can use
this research program for it so we have
different projects that are completed by
our students so you can review it on our
website so I'll past the link in chat
box so from here you can review various
projects that are completed by our
students on in silico analysis of
effective biological Pathways
transcriptomic analysis and many
more so the next question I get from the
students is what is the difference
between two months three months and six
months research program so the two month
research program is tailored for
beginners who want to start their career
areer in B informatics research with
predefined data fs and questions those
students can enroll for two months
program and for the students who want to
opt for three months you will initiate a
research proposal and you can choose
your own data set and you can also work
on the predefined data set as well and
the six months program is toiled for the
participants who wanted to conduct
Advanced multiomic resarch so that is a
perfect way to start your bi informatics
Journey so next we have
is after completing my research program
can I publish my research work or submit
it as a desertation to fulfill my
academic requirements yes absolutely you
can submit your research project
for publication and we also provide you
with help with publication by reviewing
your
manuscripts and provide you a better
Journey for publishing your research
so that's all from my end so if you have
any questions or queries in mind you can
definitely leave them in chat box and I
will riew your queries and tell you the
details for it thank
you yes sh we do have a few queries in
the chat box later to the program there
is one query about scholarship
opportunities for the partian and
especially for the
international okay so for the
international students you can email me
at communication Atomic project.com so
we will offer you a tailored you know
these tailored project detail so you can
enroll and I'm pasting my ID in the chat
box so you can reach out to me with
your com uh research interest and I will
provide you with the
appropriate information furthermore we
can also arrange an explor also do for
you uh I have pasted my
email ID in the chat box and you can
reach out to me thank
you thank you anyone else has any other
queries related to the program structure
or
duration please feel free to um either
type in the chat or you can unmute
yourself and speak up your we have
shared the email ID in the chat box
thank you thank
you yes go
ahead and I wanted to update one thing
like we have installment options also so
we can provide you with tailored
installment options according to your
budget
uh there's a question by kuray kuray we
don't have a slack or Discord but we do
have a WhatsApp group and a Skype group
uh we'll share the links you can join
them uh I'll be pasting WhatsApp
community links in the chat box for you
all can join our WhatsApp Community as
well for further
Updates this there was one more query
related to the short multiomic Workshop
that we held last time so that was a
limited time
workshop and that
actually but we will be
having such workshops in the uh upcoming
months so you can stay tuned and follow
us on our social media channel and uh
there are any updates you will be able
to definitely
inform I hope that answers your query
thank
you sorry s can you perhaps type in chat
I guess there is some
background
all right and if anyone is interested in
having one-on-one exploratory calls to
learn more about the research program
and explore your project you can simply
email us and then we will conveniently
schedule a call on Zoom or Google meet
to address your
query
uh we'll share the email ID once again
and all right if uh anyone has any other
queries please feel free to reach out
and if no more questions are left we'll
end
the
all right then thank you so much
everyone and we look forward to seeing
you in the research Boog have a great
day
bye thank you for joining everyone
bye